- [Voiceover] This right here is the graph
of Y is equal to X to the third over six
plus one over two X.
And what I want to do in this video is
to figure out the arc
length along this curve
between X equals one and X equals two.
And so we've already highlighted that
in this purple-ish color.
So I encourage you to pause this video
and try it out on your own.
And I'll give you one hint.
Assuming that you apply
the arc length formula
correctly, it'll just be
a bit of power algebra
that you'll have to do to
actually find the arc length.
So I'm assuming you've had a go at it.
Let's work through it together.
So a few videos ago,
we got a justification
for the formula of arc length.
We got arc length, arc length is equal to
the integral from the
lower boundary in X to
the upper boundary in X,
and this is the arc length,
if we're dealing in terms
of X we could actually
deal in terms of other variables.
And so it's going to be
one plus F prime of X
squared D X.
So for this particular F of
X we just need to figure out
what F prime of X is, we
need to square it, we need to
add one to it, and then we
have to take the square root
of that.
So let's do all of that step-by-step.
So what is F prime of X going to be?
Let's see, X to the third,
the derivative of that
is three X squared.
So three X squared, three
over six is going to be
X squared over two, and
this is one half X to the
negative one is one way to think about it.
And so that's going to
be negative one half X
to the negative two.
Negative one half X to
the negative two power.
Now, what is F prime of X squared?
So it's going to be,
Actually let's just write
out what is one plus F prime
of X squared?
So it's going to be,
So one, one plus F prime of X,
F prime of X squared
is going to be equal to
it's gonna be one plus this thing squared.
And so, let's see, this
term right here squared
is going to be X to the fourth over four.
It's gonna be X to the fourth over four.
Now the product of
these times two is going
to get us negative,
Let's see X squared time
X to the negative two
which is going to be one.
And so it's going to be negative one half.
Right, I just took the
product of these two
and then multiplied that by two, yep,
it's just gonna be negative one half.
And then this term right over here squared
is going to be positive one fourth X
to the negative four.
One fourth X to the negative four.
Now let's see we have
one and a minus one half
so we can simplify them a little bit.
This is going to be
equal to X to the fourth
over four.
One minus one half is plus
one half plus one fourth,
plus one fourth X to
the negative four power.
Let me make that a little bit clearer.
X to the negative four power.
So this seems a little bit strange.
And we're going to have to
take the square root of it.
But maybe we can set this
up so that it's a product
of perfect squares, because it does look,
you know X to fourth
and let's see if we can
write this in a way
that we could recognize
how to factor it a little bit better.
So let's factor out a one fourth X
to the negative fourth power.
So this is going to be equal to
one fourth X to the negative four times,
let's see I factored that out,
so if you factor one
fourth X to the negative
fourth out of this first term, and I could
color-code 'em a little bit.
This first term, when you factor this out
is going to be X to the eighth power.
Now this term right over
here, if I factored out
a one fourth, it's going to be equal to
two X to the fourth.
So this term right over here,
once again, this powering
through the algebra part.
So plus two X to the fourth,
and then this one is
pretty straight forward.
This is just going to be equal to one.
So plus one.
Plus one.
And now this is looking interesting.
Because this one, this right over here
we could rewrite as one half
X to the negative two squared.
This is equal to, that same color,
one half X to the negative two squared.
And this over here we
could rewrite this as X
to the fourth plus,
so we write it this way,
this is going to be X to the fourth plus
one squared.
Alright, X to the fourth
times X to the fourth is
X to the eighth.
One squared is one.
The product of them times
two is two X to the fourth.
So this over here is
the same thing as that.
And so now if we wanted
to take the square root
of both sides.
So if we wanted to say the
square root of one prime
plus X squared.
Notice I'm just focusing on the algebra.
So what we've done so far
this is one plus F prime
of X squared.
Now we want to take the
square root of that.
So that's going to be
the square root of this.
And so that's going to be equal to
square root of this is,
let me just color code it,
this is going to be one half
X to the negative two power
times, times X to the fourth plus one.
Times X to the fourth plus one.
X to the fourth plus one.
I did that right, yep.
Or
I could actually, now that I did all this
to put this in a form
that I could actually
recognize, now I could
distribute things back.
This is going to be equal to one half,
X to the negative two
times X to the fourth
is X squared.
One half X squared plus one
half X to the negative two.
And if we're gonna take,
if we're gonna take,
Let me rewrite this.
That's one plus F prime of X squared.
Now let's take the definite integral.
I'm going to give myself
some space to write my D X.
So we're gonna take the definite integral,
in this case, from X equals one
X equals one to X equals two.
So this is the definite
integral from X equals one
to X equals two of this D X.
So it's going to be the
definite integral of this
from X equals one to X equals two D X.
And so this is fairly straight forward.
The anti-derivative of one half X squared
that's going to be, what?
That's going to be one,
let's see it's X to the third
and then we divide by three.
So one half divided by three is one sixth.
One sixth X to the third.
And then this is going to be,
we're going to increment,
this is gonna be X to the negative one.
We're gonna divide by
that so minus one half X
to the negative one power.
Is that right?
Did I do that?
Yep, negative one, when you
take it, yep negative two
and then this one, yep, that looks good.
And we're in the homestretch.
We're gonna evaluate it.
At two and at one.
And so we get,
when you evaluate it at two, you get
two to the third, which is eight over six
minus one half times one half.
So this is minus one fourth.
And when you evaluate it at one,
you're gonna have minus
so we're gonna subtract
evaluating it at one,
it's gonna be one sixth minus one half)
And now we just have to
evaluate these fractions.
So this is going to be, let's see
This is, if we divide,
this is four thirds,
four thirds minus one
fourth minus one sixth
and then we have plus plus one half.
Now let's see the common
denominator here would be 12.
So this is be four thirds over 12 is
16 over 12.
Alright multiply the numerator
and denominator by four.
Minus one fourth, the same
thing as three over 12.
Now this is minus two over 12.
And then we have plus six over 12.
And so this is going to be equal to,
I think we deserve at least
a little mini-drum roll
right over here.
So 16 minus three is going
to be 13 minus two is 11
plus six is 17.
So there we have it.
The length of that arc
along this curve.
Between X equals one and X equals two.
That length right over
there is 17, 17 twelfths.
Were done.